cambiado los ánimos a lo largo de la
tarde y lo que empezó aquí en el hotel
tequendama en la sede improvisada de la
candidatura de gustavo petro con caras
largas por esa suma que podían hacer
tanto sumando a federico gutiérrez junto
a rodolfo hernández una suma de 60 por
ciento está sustituido por alegría y por
cierto júbilo después del discurso de
gustavo petro en el que ha terminado con
el público gritando si se puede y es que
gustavo petro ha recordado que han
ganado y que hoy es una jornada de
fiesta la campaña y lanzar mensajes a su
contrincante y ha dicho que ni el hambre
ni la corrupción se acaban con mensajes
de texto o también ha dudado de esa
posibilidad de que los colombianos
admiren a alguien que también admira a
su vez a hitler
lluís la dupla petro márquez logró cerca
de 8 millones de votos algo similar a lo
que petro obtuvo en la segunda vuelta de
2018 contra iván duque ahora tiene el
reto de conseguir muchos más votos para
ganar la presidencia tiene este
candidato un techo difícil de sobrepasar
antes de su discurso ya el equipo nos
habían filtrado algunos datos en el que
destaca más es que nunca antes en
colombia' a un candidato que había
ganado por más del 10 por ciento en
primera vuelta no había ganado en
segunda algo que también se ha apoyado
petro en los datos y es que ha dicho que
les falta un millón de votos para
conseguir la presidencia ha vaticinado
que con nueve millones y medio puede
conseguir la presidencia y entonces ha
empezado el llamado a esos jóvenes que
no han votado también al centro al cual
ha responsabilizado de haber tenido
cuatro años de gobierno de iván duquet y
también a la ciudad de medellín
tradicionalmente conservadoras ha
dirigido a ella y es que gustavo petro
tiene ahora tres semanas por delante
para convencer también a los empresarios
y ha dicho que es la oportunidad del
cambio con su candidatura o del suicidio
con su rival